Real Housewives of Orange County Alum
Alexis bellino reveals her 15 year old
son miles is transgender my number one
goal is I want to be with my children
giving them every minute that I have
them on Tuesday the former reality star
shared the news alongside this photo
with her son first Alexis introduces him
saying quote hey world this is Miles my
transgender son he's now 15 years old so
he's seen the questions and comments
made about him on my Ig I had stopped
posting for the past few months due to
this transition in miles's life but he's
now ready to come out and to use this
platform to stop any hate or questions I
want to know who they are I guess I want
to really be in their world I want to be
in in with them not just this like don't
don't do that don't do that kind of
parent Alexis admits she refused miles's
decision at first but had a change of
heart and now knows this is what he
wants I cannot imagine the strength and
courage it took for my baby to do this
but I'm extremely proud of him and I
want everyone to understand that love
doesn't change in these situations my
son now Smiles naturally for the first
time in years my son now loves the
clothes he wears my son can breathe
knowing he can be his true self
shares three kids with her ex-husband
Jim bellino Miles his twin sister
McKenna and 16 year old son James the
two married in 2005 and divorced in
2018. Gemini are now at a place where
we're good friends and we are
understanding how to co-parent and what
we're where our places are and and yeah
so we're good we're friends which is all
we can ask for because we weren't
friends for a while and now the mom of
three is engaged to boyfriend Andy bone
he's a little Brady Bunch situation
happening in Orange County
we got them all we got six toe what's
your I think he has two step two other
step children so two to eight sixteen
Seventeen so we have like seven total as
far as Alexis appearing on the Real
Housewives again God Is My Savior my
husband is my king and my body it's
sinful well after appearing on the Bravo
show from season five through 8 she has
made guest appearances and was even
rumored to come back full time so how
was everything with Jim like as far as
co-parenting and things like that does
that work out well yes I love the
relationship that I see between Jim and
the kids and and I mean Deborah sucks
it's not easy but when E.T last spoke to
Alexis she said she thinks her time on
the show is done I love my
time that I had on housewives That Grew
me a lot it taught me a lot
I think that I have turned that chapter
I will do another Cameo I just don't
want to I just think it's that time's
that's gone
foreign